Jacob Fox and shakar Lovett for their
work in putting together a great program
go ahead and clap for our program
organizers I like that thank you
um so these are just a couple of
logistics for this week so food is
provided before the first talk so just
now and then during the breaks but lunch
you're on your own and there are some
great places of course to eat right like
everywhere around here within a three
minute walk really
um let's see what else we ask that you
always leave food outside the room we
don't bring any food in here there are
lockers on the far side of the building
on the first floor if you want to leave
your things during lunch break for
example don't leave your things
unattended it's Berkeley our campuses at
all campuses but just don't do it
um our videographer Omid far will be
helping speakers get set up for talks I
don't needs in his in his professional
Booth over there finally um I would like
to give a special thanks you may see
them popping in and out Elizabeth and
Ashley from the Simons Institute events
team for managing all the logistics for
this week including accommodations for
our out of town visitors
and now I'm going to hand things over to
Hamid is that right yeah um who will say
a few more words about the workshop
thanks
yeah there's free yeah
thank you so welcome everybody I'm glad
that many of you made it and could come
to this Workshop
so one small thing I want to say is that
the talks are most of the talks are one
hours and there's a lot of talks every
day four hours four talks for most of
the days and um so something that some
feedback we got from the previous
Workshop is that you don't have to
really go all the way use all your one
hour I mean you can if you want but but
you can leave 10 minutes for questions
or discussions if you if you if you
don't have enough material to say like
don't feel pressured to use all the one
hour and uh yeah other than that so just
have you face the workshop
thank you
all right thank you it's a great
pleasure and honor to give the first
talk of this Workshop so I'll tell you
about a work song
is that and the title and also the
statement of main theorem is a nearly
all case set functions are you made
you see the pen or should I try a
different okay
if you want me to switch a pen just like
so nearly okay set functions are unique
and this is Joint work
with
a ballock
yeah
with my grad student Harvard
Bernard
is
also my grad student
okay so the basic question here
so the basic question here is
how many KSAT functions are there on N
variables
thank you
in this talk I'm primarily going to
think of K as fixed and N go into
Infinity well our comment on what
happens when K is increasing at some
point
that's a lot of times
okay so just to clarify the notation and
the setup so what I mean by a case add
function
is a Boolean function from
and Boolean variables to one output
Boolean variable that has a certain form
right for concreteness we're going to
work with dnfs
the disjunctive normal form so for
example a freesat
would be
something like a function taking in an
input Boolean variables and having some
formula which
consists of various Clauses each Clause
being the end of three literals that
could be positive or negated literals
and then or of another clause
at and so on so forth so that's an
example of a three-step so this is
a dnf but equivalently you can also
consider CNF so this is an or of n's a
CNS or ends of ores for the purpose of
counting functions the negation of
a
dnf is a CNF and vice versa so for the
purpose of counting these functions it
doesn't matter which form you use
so this is okay
so each class the width of each Clause
this case but you could have like a
million
extract the number of costs
so how many cases functions are there on
and variables and also what does a
typical one look like
two
so let me first clarify the confusion
people often ask when they hear about
this problem which is that this is not
about whether a random case that formula
is satisfied right so that's a different
line of work also very important for
which there's some important
breakthroughs namely the solution of the
satisfiability conjecture this is not
about that right so this is about KSAT
functions
Okay so
distributions
that's right yeah so take all functions
Express while it's case app
that's what the typical structure of
such a function is right so it's mostly
but there will be other formulations
I'll see later
so let's first get some easy upper back
the total number of functions
from
and variables to end to one output
variable there's two to the two to the
end
so that's that's an upper Bell
the number of
case that classes
you have two n possible literals to put
in each position and K different
positions so let me just write down this
down to the end to the K so then the
number of
case that functions
is 2 to this quantity because I can
include each such cause or not so
already for a 6K and large n you see
that the number of K side functions is a
tiny fraction of number of total
functions
let me also explain some lower bound
constructions
we can consider monotone
functions
so monotone functions is a function that
can be expressed using a formula
involving only positive literals
[Music]
so excitement we do not use x i bar okay
so we do not use XL bar
so these are monotone functions
the number of monotone functions
is well
and shoulders n choose K possible
Clauses and two to and choose
that's the number of monotone functions
here there's a small caveat I'm using
I'm assuming all the Clauses have
distinct variables but let's not worry
about
unite means that the formula or the
function is monotone after first
negating a subset of variables
cool
so for example you start with a monotone
formula and then you say that I'm going
to negate all the instances of X2
and again all the instances of X5
so that's that would be an example of a
unique function
the number of unique functions is also
not too hard to estimate
basically you give me a pneumonotonal
function
and a choice of which
variables to negate
there's a bit of over counting here
because a formula might not use all the
variables but that represents a
negligibly small fraction of all
functions so let me not worry too much
about it so it's up to one plus little
one
error
that's quantitation
okay a number of unit functions yes
the stat quantity
so
so this problem was first
studied in systematically in the paper
by olabash Brightwell and leader
and they conjectured that for a fixed
okay
the number of
casa
functions
and variables
is
this quantity here
coinciding with the asymptotics of the
number of unit functions so an
equivalent formulation of this
conjecture is that one minus total one
fraction
all
KSAT functions
are unique
let me say a few words about the history
of this conjecture
so this paper by Boulevard and leader
they proved a weaker version of the
conjecture for k equals to 2 showing
that the number of two Sat functions is
2 to the one plus little one and choose
two so the uh so the weaker asymptotics
because one plus local one is in the
exponent
foreign
Peter Allen proved that for k equals to
2 in 2007
and then
elinka and Kong
12 proved it for k equals to 3.
and
in our work we proved this conjecture
for okay
has two parts so the first part
is a paper with my students ding ding
and nitya we proved that for all k
this problem can be reduced
to a conjecture
which has the form of a hypergraph
like Turon problem
so I presented this work at a workshop
which then got some people interested
and then together with additionally with
Bernard and um and Yoshi balog we
managed to solve
this
your own problem
and this proves
BL conjecture
so I want to tell you about this work
and the ideas in this proof
so
the problem about asymptotic enumeration
okay so the statement can be phrased in
terms of typical structure about you
know what we're really doing is finding
some upper bound to the number of KSAT
functions and there's a rich history of
asymptotic enumeration in graph Theory
and in combinatorics and I think that
analogy is incredibly useful uh you know
when we were thinking about this problem
and also a good way for me to explain
some of the key ideas so let me first
revisit some of the
history and key ideas on combinatorial
asymptotic enumerations
and here the motivating question is how
many triangle free graphs are there on
inverter system
foreign
this is a great problem okay so this
problem was solved in the 70s by eredos
Kleinman and Rothschild but just because
it was some people you know still kept
thinking about it and sure came up with
a lot of wonderful combinatorics
including some of the most exciting
results in the past decade in
combinatorics
so I want to explain a brief history of
what are some of the ideas around this
problem and also explain what this has
to do with that because right now they
look kind of different but I want to
relate to these two problems to each
other
just to give a very quick history of
things that are relevant so a old result
in extremograph theory mental serum and
later toront's theorem tells us that
every n vertex
okay triangle free
graph has at most
n Square over four edges
and this is tight because of the
complete bipart Digraph example
and this work of headers Kleinman and
Rothschild
73 so they show two I mean they did a
lot of things in this paper but let me
first phrase the answer to this question
in a slightly weaker way which is that
the number of triangle free
graphs and vertices
is 2 to the one plus little one
N squared over 4 in the exponent
and this is sharp because if you start
with a complete bipartite graph then
every subgraph is also triangle free and
which is you get this number
they showed a stronger result that 1
minus little one fraction
all
and vertex triangle free graphs are
bipart
okay
so this is a much stronger result
labeled vertices
yeah the question is whether it's on and
labeled vertices or unlabeled vertices
and turns out in this case it doesn't
matter because that contributes to much
smaller term
does this imply the Ebola bash result
the bounds are similar Audrey okay
you're asking is how is this related to
that okay so not yet right but certainly
you see the analogy so there's an
analogy
um so let me say a little bit about the
techniques and how these things are
related to each other on the sport
it's a pretty short paper but yeah the
techniques
and little work has clarified some
unifying techniques with those type of
problems in particular the regularity
method allows you to prove this Bound by
a standard application and regularity
and more recently the typograph
container method
I'll write this down because they'll
play an important role in this talk the
hypergraph container method
so this is an important breakthrough
about 10 years ago separately due to
Pollock more samurkey and Saxton
Thomason so it's an important advance in
combinatorics that gives a very powerful
method for handling problems such as
this one and by assuming a powerful
theorem one can quickly deduce this part
a
to deduce Part B you need to do some
more work that's more bespoke to the
problem that you're looking at but
essentially a stability type result
so and largely I will ignore this part
from the story that I will tell today
because it is quite more Technical and
or distract from my main message
so the hypergraph container method let
me
you know since I think not everybody
here is from the combinatorics community
so let me give a very quick sketch of
what the main idea in applying the
hypergraph container method is so what
inform us how to think about the KSAT
problem
s
there's a sketch of applying containers
to the problem of counting triangle free
graphs
so there's some theorem which is a
container theorem and by applying it to
this problem we get a collection
thank you
of what are called containers
where each container is
a n vertex graph
and okay for each container
as
a small number of patches
so slightly over the threshold in mental
serum just a little bit uh
over the number of edges in mentals
theorem
and
also there are not too many containers
the total number of graphs is and to the
on the word of N squared so this not too
many containers
and importantly the reason why they're
called containers is that every triangle
free graph
and vertices is a subgraph of some
container
and once you have a collection of
containers with this property which is
what the powerful container theorem
yeah new then you can deduce
that the number of triangle free graphs
is at most well
I sum over all containers see
and
for each container I look at all its
possible subgraphs and I know that this
counts all triangle free graphs because
every graph Falls in some container
well the number of containers is 2 to
the little O N squared
and the number of edges in each
container is bounded by this quantity
here
the first result
there's a lot of stuff happening in
deducing the existence of this
collection but once you have it you can
quickly deduce the result and another
way to kind of say morally what's going
on is the container theorem gives you a
very efficient way to do Union balance
in a particular setting that has to do
with avoiding triangle free
wedding triangles
now in applying this container method
what one often has to do in a typical
application
is
to solve we need to solve some identify
and solve some extremal problem
Maybe
there was this Mentos theorem
which
is related to
this quantity
okay so there's some problem that you
need to solve like that
and then
one also needs to do something called
supersaturation which
for dense problems basically comes for
free and for the problems that we're
dealing with here where we're looking at
a positive density fraction of edges
that always comes for free so let's not
worry about that today but in many
important applications the container
method supersaturation is a key
bottleneck
okay
well I hope this is a
clear explanation of how to count
triangle free graphs
then what I want to explain next is how
this has to do with the problem that we
started talking about namely counting
KSAT functions
which seems to be a different kind of
object right so what do they have to do
with each other
otherwise
okay yeah so there's also the regularity
method which can do many of same things
um and
a couple things one is that it's a lot
more difficult to apply the regularity
method especially for higher uniformity
or larger cake
and also it gives worse balance
especially when you want to consider
sparser objects
okay
so
I want to explain
how to view the problem of enumerating
k-start functions through the lens of
avoiding forbidden subgraphs
talk about Counting
okay
the number of cases functions foreign
function has a formula
it may have more than one
but it only has at least one and you can
also consider
a formula that is minimal in the sense
that
no Clause is redundant right
what I mean by minimal you take a
formula maybe if you delete a class
nothing changes about the function and I
just delete that clause
so so every function has at least one
representative as a minimal case of
formula they might have more than one
actually it turns out a corollary of our
result
is that
most or almost all
have
a unique
that will be a corollary of the theorem
okay but for now this is an inequality
now this formula can be quite
complicated
and it turns out that we can focus on a
class formula which we'll call simple
minimal case platform
simple here as in simple graphs what I
mean is that no
no true clauses
use the exact same set of K variables
for example
if you have both x y z and x y z bar
that's not allowed
it turns out
you can rule out non-simple formulas
they don't occupy so much space and
let's focus on the simple ones
I want you to imagine a simple formula
uniform hypergraph with some decorations
on the edges right you start with n
variables
and we put edges K uniform edges among
these variables and they have some
additional information about which
variables are negated or not but it
essentially looks like a k uniform
hypergraph
but there are some forbidden structures
in the scale uniform hypergraph namely
those that correspond to non-minimality
for example
the
this
K2 size formula okay so remember this if
I uh this is the end and the commas mean
or so this is non-minimal
it's not minimal because it's not
possible to only satisfy the first
clause
you can try right so you can try set in
values and then you'll eventually
satisfy something else it's not possible
to only satisfy this one
but this is non-minimal and and you
should view this as some kind of a
forbidden sub graph
now there are lots and lots of forbidden
configurations
they're infinitely many forbidden
but
what
what one should do is Zone in
fix a special set of forbidden
configurations
so a number of simple
ASAP
formula now no longer necessarily
minimal
but avoiding
a prefixed
set
of
non-minimal
platforms
pick some space finite set
forbidden configurations as I'm just not
going to allow them and instead of
considering mineral one minimal ones I'm
going to consider formula
avoiding the setup
configurations sub formula
okay
any questions so far
is there a reason to believe like our
priori that restricting to finite set of
sub formulas will give it time left
round so the question is is there a
reason to believe that it's enough for a
bit of finite set now that's a great
question and a priorino
right so it turns out yes but a priority
absolutely not
okay
for graphs
so hypergraphs things can get very
different yeah
so
what we will do is show that a typical
minimal case that formula is in fact
unique and we'll do this VI container
counting strategy
so here's a container strategy
it's supposed to mirror what happens for
counting triangle free graphs but it's
actually more complicated
and it's because when you apply the
container method to count triangle free
graphs you end up with an extremal
problem which is about triangle free
graphs
what we're trying to
count minimal case that formula or these
ones that avoid some fixed set of
non-minimal sub formula
we through our analysis get some extreme
or problem
but now this problem is lived inside a
more complicated space
and I want to explain you know what is
that more complicated space
so containers what are containers in
this case
so this is now kind of viewing it from
hindsight so it turns out the right
containers
what the The RK style formula
but of a certain special kind
place our formula that can happen to be
semi-simple
so I want to explain what we mean by
so simple formula are ones where if you
think about the hyper graph there are no
double edges
so semi-simple means that
we so compared to a simple graph so
simple formula we um allow up to two
classes on every set of K variables so
every
K variables
support
at most two classes
and
if they support two
then the two Clauses differ by negation
on exactly one variables
here's an example
in this formula I would
allow
these two so X
y con okay X not y z and X not y not Z
to both be present because they differ
on exactly Z
but
this would not be allowed
that's the definition of semi-simple so
it's a little bit more than simple but
we allow some double edges but double
edges have to be of a specific type
okay so containers they turn out to be
semi-simple formula so so this is why I
say it's in a way more complicated than
what happens for the problem of counting
triangle free graphs because somehow
when you go through this Machinery you
end up with a more complicated space of
objects consider which I think is
interesting so it's interesting how this
happens and it's
I would say that this is not a
limitation of our method it's an
essential future
now I'll say that the
main Insight or one of the main insights
from our first work in this reducing the
problem two or hypergraph container
method the two typograph two run problem
is in distilling what exactly is the
right structure to study and Distilling
what might be the minimal uh non-minimal
subformula to forbid
already here you can go through the
container machinery and come up with
some extremo problem but it's going to
have a lot of forbidden structures
that's maybe too unwieldy to analyze
and so an Insight here is to forget some
non-essential structures and we're going
to forget
some things
and reduce
convert
these things to what we call partially
directed hypergraphs
foreign
so it's best to explain this through an
example
suppose I have
four variables so it's n equals to four
and k equals to three
consider a formula with some number of
Clauses and I want to convert such a
formula into some partially directed
free graph
if I see foreign
x y z bar I'm going to put an edge on X
Y Z
hypergraph I'm going to put an edge and
I will forget about some negative
negation structures
if I see a slightly simple Edge
x y z x Y Bar
x y w x y bar
like that okay so so this is a
semi-simple clause they differ on
exactly y I'm going to convert that to
a directed Edge
so the directed Edge will be on x y w
with a point
it's directed towards y
so here a direction means the selected
vertex y Point The Edge towards a vertex
and that vertex is chosen
According to which
variable you have the negated difference
so this is a conversion
from
semi simple formula to
these objects partially directed
hypergraphs
question yeah
that's why definitely not an X Y Bar
just
just equivalently identify them as a
single two clause
but so is the reason not to do that why
do you want to read it yeah so it gets
to a very subtle point which I think may
be better to discuss offline which is
that these things are not we're trying
to count simple minimal formula
and these things arise to us because
they were looking at containers so it's
not about counting these guys we don't
actually care about counting certain
symbol for me we care about structure of
the containers
this is a
it's a fine point
I don't I only care about counting
simple for me but we have to analyze
this semisable formula because of the
method
okay
so
there are some forbidden configurations
and let me give you one example
forbidden configuration
okay
and the fourth window configuration is
this partially directed triangle the
triangle with a partially directed Edge
directed Edge
it turns out this is forbidden okay and
let me kind of say informally in what
sense is this forbidden
in that
if you have
a structure which corresponds to and
converts to this subgraph
then it's to blow up while containing a
simple non-minimal sub formula
so there's some subtlety to it but maybe
the thing to remember is that these
things cause you problems okay so yeah
these things in in the container then
they will cause you problems and so they
turn out to be forbidden
okay now
we have this collection of containers
not so many containers because of the
container theorem
and the number of
simple sub formula
of some container
foreign
for each undirected Edge I can either
pick the class or not so 2 to the number
of undirected edges
and then three to the number of directed
edges
directed Edge then I can either not
choose a classroom here or choose one of
the two to get my simple sub formula
and then the extremal problem
is to show that this quantity here is no
more than
what we're trying to prove for the total
number of case ad formulas
and because we have a small number of
containers summing over all the
containers will get us basically the
result was a slightly weaker result
asymptotically
analysis so
if you have a container where this
exponent is too large
then I don't have a bound
but if all the containers have that this
quantity is at most that so the extreme
problem is to show
this
if this is true for every container
right I want this true for every
container
and then I'm in good shape
[Music]
so the balance number of containers is
it's small it's a more precise sounds
but
following the K equals two case uh but
you'll see that basically the same story
you turned out before
you know that little set of prefix
advantage of it in some numbers depends
okay I'll tell you exactly what it is
okay all great questions
but really it's a linear question the
types and edges because you think that's
right yeah so it's it's too long type
problem with all Edge and I'll State
exactly what the result the problem
result is
another question that nobody asked maybe
I preempted is that this gives you the
weaker result we're asking products in
the exponent if you want a stronger
result there are actually quite
technical but additional arguments
can't work out a lot about argument
so there's some very technical arguments
that essentially stability arguments
allow you to get from here to a much
tighter result
this first is like a rough count and
then you have like
yeah so with the weight is stability
arguments usually work is that you say
you feel very far from your desired
configuration that you have that drop
down if you're very close then you have
much more control over the actual
structure close to the weight and then
yeah oh I see it first yeah how how bad
is the level of one the content these
kind of statements uh how bad is the
dependence we haven't worked without but
you know we're using
dependencies
you're just saying that right now just
the application
that's right okay
so now with the last part of the park I
want to tell you what is the extreme
problem the more precisely and what is
the result of the extreme part
so
talk about the extreme
work
so here is
a typical theorem again continuing what
happens for two set
we will write throughout Alpha to be the
density
undirected edges
the total number divided by n choose K
and then beta to be the density of
directed edges
so
here's something that we know is true in
a
partially directed graph
that avoids this configuration
so in a two PDG that avoids this
configuration and by the way another
technical point is that by avoiding this
I mean also any further directions like
for example that is also forbidden if I
avoid this then that is also first
dwell too much on that okay so you know
two PDG that avoids this for clinical
configuration
we have
Alpha Plus
two beta is at most one plus the whole
one
so this is some two on type resulting
for forbidden configuration then some
weighted Edge count is at most something
two turns out to be tight actually both
numbers not to be tight and the example
is either you have a complete set of
undirected edges or
all directed edges from one half to
another half
and
furthermore
this results through all of that
framework would imply the
main conjecture for Tucson
basically because of everything I said
and hand waved Earth so this is the
extreme problem that was discussed
earlier that result implies that well
over here is that there's two okay so so
this implies in particular Alpha plus
log base two or three beta is almost one
plus little one because two is bigger
than log base 203
and and if you take log two or both
sides then then that inequality is this
inequality that we want to show
all right
what happens then for larger values of K
spell it up
for what happens for threesat
which is that in a
reset free PDG that avoids some
particular structure and let me tell you
exactly what structure is
it's a generalization of this director
triangle where I add a common vertex to
all three edges still has three edges
and add a common vertex to all three
edges
so you start with this that's a two PDG
and add one vertex that's common to
everything
forbid that structure
then we still get
Alpha plus
log base 203 beta is at most one plus
total one
that turns out to be true
although in this case we do not know
what is the optimal constant here but
for the purpose of the case act
injection this is true
and it would then also imply PDL
injector for
it and more generally for
hey sap what I would do is replace the
thing in the middle by
K minus two vertices so that this is a
structure that is forbidden
okay
so
in a way this is okay so this is the
content of the second paper as well as
mentioned there were two parts so let me
just say a quick word about how we ended
up proving that
the short answer is that we used the
method of flag algebras
well what that is essentially is a sum
of squares proof so we managed to find
some sum of squares certificate
to solve this problem you see that we
have to do it for every case so you know
it's not simply some numerical output we
have to keep a formula but it was
actually pretty essential that we used
computer help to guide us because
there's too many possibilities right the
guide is to find the pattern and then we
can write down a very short certificate
so so let me just
where am I it's a very short certificate
let me let me now write it down for you
so it's you can you can it's takes a
page to verify that it doesn't take a
computer to verify you can verify in the
page but it's very short certificate
so so that's in a nutshell how we prove
that so let me say the remaining time
just discuss some further questions I I
think you know where does this lead next
depends okay
sum of squares proof uh I'm not quite
sure how to answer that but the number
of terms does not
um
I mean the uniformity goal gets larger
and larger but but kind of the shape of
the proof is is constant location
okay
so
in this paper of all about sprywell
leader okay so they
proposed quite provocatively a
theory of random case ad functions
is that you know there are trying to
study you know through this conjecture
and through this work
um
so what does this mean right so well
it's what I talked about if you take a
random case out function what does it
look like whether it's properties and in
that vein I want to propose a couple of
directions or just mention a couple
directions in analogy to what we study
for random graphs
so what we've done so far is counting
cases formulas which is like counting
graphs or studying GM one half
of course you know we now do a lot more
than GN one half so there are a couple
of natural directions to go further one
is
so the subsequent work of all of us and
Brightwell they conjecture that
if you let K increase with n
and the conjecture that if K is at least
uh or below half n and a little bit then
the number of case app functions
foreign
asymptotically given by the same formula
our techniques get nowhere close to this
and we can let K increase maybe a tiny
bit
I don't want to say anything on the
record but you know maybe log login or
something like that
um
that's not on the record
but it's nowhere close to
um
right so then you can ask well what is a
threshold in k for which the typicality
structure is still holds
another Direction
is analogous to sparse random graphs
here there are several different ways to
formulate this question and one way
which I think is quite natural is what
is the typical structure of a minimal
case that formula
with M depending on N clauses
so what we study is a dense case where m
is essentially on the order of n to the
k
but
like in random graphs it's a sparse or
formula and then what happens again this
is different from
satisfiability of random formula problem
which
is well that's really in the regime of
taking a linear number of Clauses and
asking for satisfiability
here we're conditioning on already being
minimal and very few formulas are
minimal a conditional minimal what this
typical structure
so you asked a typical structure but do
you know how many there are
Okay so
the question is what's the relationship
between typical structure and commonly
and they are what if you can describe
the typical structure then it's usually
pretty easy to write down the formula
for the elimination so they're related
just like once you know it's Unique and
it's pretty easy to accomplishment
okay that's all
any questions
about the statement that most times
right you know what Edge density regime
is that ruined because once you take
like Sparks enough to access yeah no
it's a great question yeah this has been
variable study um I think the answer is
around intensively one over root f
this is something that's extremely
awesome and the container method there's
a modern perspective that's very
powerful tool precisely for that kind of
questions
thanks
for those of us who haven't seen the use
of sound squares in this context and can
you say a few words about that oh okay
so let me think about what I can say
um
but let me write down some version of
the certificate right one without all
the the degree right so
um you know there will be some statement
which has this form
just to give you a shape of what
such a sum of square certificate might
look like
so what does this mean
um here okay you can either view this as
a formula sorry
X yes
so I have some graph and I pick random
vertices x y and x k minus 1 and then Y
and Z and I asked what's the probability
that that is an edge what's the
probability that this is a directed Edge
probably have this is not an edge that
is an edge that's not an edge that's a
directed Edge
and this is true okay so so this is true
and it is true because I can rewrite
this formula as a sum of squares
I can rewrite that sum of squares and
then when uh and then because this is
true
um
Okay so
and then you notice that this thing here
so let me take back the last thing I
said it is true because they're actually
only finally in many cases to check
foreign
and then notice that whatever is in this
red bracket is a square
a square 280 B squared that is a square
so that's non-negative so I can just
erase the whole thing and I get what I
want
like that okay
so what was this finite name anything to
check so that part is not the sum of
squares yeah so
they are K plus one vertices yeah and
then they only
basically finally many possible
configurations on K plus one vertices
and then we can just Case by case check
that for every single configuration
where the Forbidden structure is
enforced this is true
so you check all of the cases by hand
they're only really like three different
cases
so what were the previous proofs for k
equal to 3 looks like the previous okay
what are the previous proof of K plus 3
look like so so
before using flag algebra another
approach is that if you know that the
density you know whatever this thing
you're trying to do is always true on
six vertices or five vertices then it is
true for water graphs as well by
sampling
so you can just check all the
configurations of Pi vertices
now the five gets pretty large yes and
as K goes up so this doesn't quite work
it's obstacle uh it doesn't quite work
computationally for larger values okay
two questions the first one is that
generally extreme problems for directive
graphs are apart and a basic example is
if you cut a high cost
degree condition that would imply to
have a directive triangle
for that and for hyper graphs there are
also part like uh we don't know what the
optimal events we use for foreign
problem for a very long time right uh
and to this thing we still don't know
either for k equals three what is the
optimal constant there and that's closer
to the classical hypograph trial problem
uh but actually in you know in our world
we especially you know in our third year
parts of our work we took a lot of
inspiration from the cases of hypergraph
term problems that have been solved
including for our final plane so it's
actually that I didn't know that before
so
from
yeah basically is known for our type for
the final plane and there's some really
nice techniques involved adaptive and
all of those things were quite useful
so the the second question is uh I know
one other example were the five algebra
approach
one actually learned information from
that and then was able to generalize for
General Tay and that's the writers quick
density theorem so this is the second
example in alera do you know other
examples it seems like a generally a
good idea for some general problem that
you might see what's going on
so you're asking for examples of flag
algebra proofs which are not numerical
but that's how it works for infinite
the wires that is
um so when you tell this problem did you
start by trying cable four first and k
equals five or did you just we're going
to solve it for all K we try small cases
we work very hard you have like a proof
that only work for cables four K plus
five at one point or
um right so in in yeah so we initially
had you know before the flag algebra
approved we had a proof which actually
was quite nice for k equals before
there's some nice things about that
proof too but I won't get into it and
then
um there's a Lithia to work with a high
school student and for you and really
brute force that proof of k equals to
five by a very massive computer search
I don't think we could do one okay
because I do remember at some point like
four and five has been done but not okay
and then that's you guys didn't do it
for this computer like uh search you did
did you try to force it somehow to spit
out like small certificates or something
or it was just a lot lucky to do it okay
great so um yeah the question is like
you know how do we get something which
is quite nice there was a lot of
interactivity right so we really wanted
a proof which is not just the proof book
app let's say rank one or there's few
terms so that we could
um eyeball it and figure out what's
going on and in fact this proves even
strangely only works for hey at least
four
it doesn't work for smaller values okay
some of the numerics will work out for
smaller values so here and in a way we
were also lucky that such a proof Works
in general but could you force that the
rank is a small for the certificate
somehow like when you did your computer
search so you should ask an article
expert in uh actually doing computation
with these so I accountable please
the question is if you try to run SOS
proofs on a computer because it's
something random but can you can you
kind of constrain the rank I think you
know maybe in practice there are some
methods to try to force them right there
to be nice
you wrote down and actually correspond
to a non-minimal uh formula did you say
something about two blocks so I said
something very quickly so which is that
these things don't correspond to
non-minimal but if you have a formula
that converts to this one then the two
blow up
that's going to cost you problems but
two blow up on that formula that's going
to contain some
or any sub formula will contain a
contribution what's the tubular formula
yeah so think about the triple of a
graph you double all the vertices so two
mobile formula you double all the
variables and then two Decay times
precisely okay all right I guess uh it's
time to secure again
[Applause]
questions
if I do register